as the novel coronavirus continues to
spread more and more cities are
escalating their tactics to keep the
virus at bay asking people to socially
distance and in some cases to shelter in
place but some are not so lucky to have
the ability to work from home dr. Eric
Choi Pena an emergency physician and the
director of global health for northwell
health gave us some tips for staying
safe at work the number one thing to do
is wash your hands either 20 seconds
with soap and water or with a hand
sanitizer that's greater than 60%
alcohol um because the main mode of
transmission is gonna be touching
surfaces that someone is coughed or
sneezed on and then touching your face
so that's your first line of defense is
hand-washing so companion hand sanitizer
to soap and water if you have the
ability to use soap and water that's
your best bet so hand sanitizer is a
quick way to disinfect your hands in
between soaking water washes but soap
and water really does have a greater
Africa scene washing away droplets
washing away viral particles and
removing any soil or contaminants on
your hands where buyers could be hitting
underneath this hand sanitizer
essentially is a superficial clean so if
you've got no dirt and no grime on your
hands and use hand sanitizer it is
effective at killing most things that
are on your hands but anytime you have
any type of dirt or anything else where
something could be hiding underneath
that layer of dirt hand sanitizer isn't
gonna get it with water and soap will um
I also recommend at the beginning of the
day and wiping down areas that you're
gonna touch often in your work area so
keyboards phones Mouse I would disinfect
with any any householder or business in
fact it would work one of the other ways
to catch the virus is to be in close
contact with other people being next to
another human being for greater than 2
minutes within 6 feet
who's sick and showing symptoms
definitely is a risk the idea right now
is we want to practice some social
distancing between people so that if
someone is sick we're not within six
feet of them as much as possible the
other thing is avoiding gatherings of
you know greater than five people that
aren't absolutely essential to business
is probably a good a good temporary
measure
but social distancing is not always
feasible especially when your work
involves person-to-person contact so the
service is a tough area and they're
especially tough because they also don't
have any sick time often if they don't
work they're not making money so that's
something the society is in general we
have to take a look at because you know
they really do have kind of a financial
and carrot 'iv to work butanol sick so
the worst thing someone in the service
injury industry could do is work while
sick but the things that they can do to
protect themselves disinfect their hands
make sure that every time they're
touching someone else's credit card
touching a check touching touching
something that another human being is
touched in the course of their job that
before they do anything like certainly
eat or touch their face but they're
disinfecting with what soapy water or
hand sanitizer the handshake is a tough
thing because it's really ingrained in
our culture right I mean you know even
now you know and I'm meeting people part
of me is like resisting the urge to
extend my hand out and shake people's
hands so I think having something was a
gesture the elbow is certainly I think
the safer thing than the fist but I'm
just having that momentary contact with
an area that's not going to go anywhere
near your face you know even just kind
of a slight nod or a bow oftentimes they
get kind of the the job done we need to
keep calm we have to kind of take this
with the appropriate level of
seriousness protect the people that are
at risk of having worse outcomes the
rest of us need to just kind of take the
anxiety down one-match realize that
we're gonna get food else it's gonna be
here it's gonna pass through our
communities and so we really just need
to kind of do things that are smart but
try to avoid panic
[Music]